at the root of the show is a guy who's
really looking for the second act of his
life
who's your shadow you're pretending you
don't know he doesn't know that shade he
used to play hockey professionally for a
lot of money she's a priestly placemat
shade a former pro hockey player
entering the next phase of his life off
the ice shadow come on man you're not
something about that situation in
Albuquerque the career trajectory of a
professional athlete is not that
different from the career trajectory of
an entertainer I seem to have been able
to to maintain my career for a very long
time thankfully touchwood but a lot of
that has had to do with me being able to
reinvent myself
Matt reinvents himself as a private
investigator Oh Matt shade that's a pee
I named if I ever heard one
it isn't it as a hockey player Matt was
an instigator what he lacked in skill he
made up for and being able to to read
his opponents and anticipate what his
opponents were gonna do he utilizes
those skills as a private investigator
his new career sees him teaming up with
another investigator whose style is very
different baby who the hell are you
imagine ever be I your dad well he's a
hothead that's used to getting his own
way and having people fawn over him so
and I'm more of a stickler when it comes
to rules that all you got kid you don't
hate kids
especially kids I'm trying to talk there
is friction there is friction but
sometimes friction can lead to sparks
you